okay so coming to the last lecture of
this series on logic and quantum
information so we've already seen that
when our main focus has been on
probabilistic models those arising from
quantum mechanics and those as it were
around it relating to the non contextual
models and then these signaling models
but we've also seen that a lot of
information a surprising amount of
information about the probabilistic
behavior can be gained by looking just
at the supports just at the possible it
ik information from the model as we
might say where we just distinguish
between probability zero impossible and
positive probability namely possible now
I want to take that a bit further and
also put it in a in a more general
context so I want to start by taking the
notion of distributions and giving it a
a useful and quite simple generalization
as a more general setting for this
interplay between probabilistic and
possible istic notions and I've as I've
said at the beginning I'm sort of
cutting out all the all the measure
theory issues by restricting to discrete
probabilities probability distributions
of finite support actually most of the
sets we've been considering have been
finite anyway
and in this case and that makes it very
simple to make this generalization so a
probability distribution of finite
support can just be viewed as a function
into the non-negative reals which is
nonzero only on a finite number of
arguments and which normalizes and the
fact that it normalizes their guarantees
at the range lies in the unit interval
and then the probability of an event is
easily defined from this just by summing
over the values assigned to the elements
okay now what we can do in a very
straightforward way as to general to say
that we're using the non-negative reals
as our as the range of our functions and
we could replace this by an arbitrary
commutative semi ring which has
sufficient algebraic structure for all
the operations we need to set up the the
basic notions of probability theory
still to make sense and I think Val will
probably be using semi rings in his
there we are
we aim to serve so so it's a very useful
notion that occurs obviously in many
places in in computer science but so
it's just it's like a ring but where the
additive structure is only assumed to be
a Mon ID and where will be a commutative
monoid and we'll be interested in the
case where the multiplication is
commutative as well and the key thing is
that they have this distributive law so
the non-negative reals that's why I use
them rather than the unit interval
because we have normalization anyway so
it's algebraically convenient to say
that the structure were working in is
the non-negative reals and that's a semi
ring Mata ring and the distributions we
get on that are exactly the discrete
probability distributions on the other
hand we could put in any distributive
lattice and in particular the boolean 'z
as the semi ring and with disjunction
and conjunction playing the roles of
addition and multiplication so if I put
the boolean Xin what is the what is the
notion of distribution mean it small
exercise just to check that we were at
all they can mix the beginning of the
lecture now some what is a distribution
in the case of the boolean ziz the semi
ring variant this is our definition of a
distribution
descent sorry asset but can you be more
specific
sorry and on empty set is true and even
more than that finite support so a
finite not sorry did you say finite the
finite non empty set finite support and
the normalization condition so finite
non empty of course as I say most it
will be applying this to finite sets
anyway but the exact rendition in the
boolean case of what a distribution is
is a finite non empty set and you see so
there's a which brings of course a lot
of examples familiar from the computer
science into play and will be shortly
looking at her salient example of that
and there are lots of other
possibilities we could we could sort of
have a kind of bag semantics somewhat
analogous to what photon was talking
about in the previous lecture by taking
the natural numbers as the semi ring all
that yeah in fact if we took the reals a
ring and therefore a semi ring that
would give us exactly signed measures of
the kind that we saw came up naturally
we were in the set where we're thinking
as it were of negative probabilities
some all of these are interesting
examples in our context now i've de
category fide my lecture but I haven't
going to mention the word functor here
so we can given a set you can define the
set of all our distributions
parameterize by this choice of semi ring
are our distributions of finite support
and it's a functor in exactly the same
way that the probability case is and
actually if you define it exactly the
way that you see the factorial action is
just this fundamental operation of
pushing a measure forward along a map
and even though probabilists don't
usually speak a functors they're always
using this push push forward action of
functions on measures measurable
functions in general of course on
measures and statisticians use it to
when you talk about the distribution of
a random variable around
variable is really a measurable function
defined from a measure space into a
measurable space and the distribution of
the variable is the push forward of the
measure on its domain which you could
therefore avoid mentioning ever
afterwards to the to the codomain which
is usually the reals so and one can then
check that this action on on maps is
actually front toriel which again is
used all the time whether one
acknowledges it or not
okay so I've made my homage to category
theory here I think as I mentioned
funked now we have this general notion
of distribution and now in the case in
the boolean case as we just said boolean
distributions two element boolean
algebra as the as the semi ring they
just give us subsets and in the boolean
and the point is we can run all the
notions that we've had till now in this
more general case of our value
distributions and in the boolean case it
gives us a notion of possible estate
contextual ax t where we've replaced
probabilities by boolean values and the
crucial difference of course is that you
have disjunction as the addition and
idempotent operations you're losing all
counting information now there's a
homomorphism in fact a unique
homomorphism units have to be preserved
of semi rings from the non-negative
reals to the boolean it's the only one
there is which sends positive
probabilities to 1 and 0 to 0 and where
you get a once you've got distributions
over a semi ring if you have a
homomorphism of semi rings you can
translate distributions across this and
this will say exactly in this case send
a probability distribution to its
support and this in turn will send
probabilistic empirical models to
possible istic empirical models so this
is the sort of general context in which
that arises in that fashion by the way
it's a nice little exercise to check
that there's no homomorphism from the
reals as a semi ring to the
Lien's and that sort of well we'll see
why that sort of relates to that fact we
mentioned the other day about having
hidden variables at the cost of having
signed measures or negative
probabilities but in this case where
we're going from the non-negative reals
to the billions the induced map on
distributions is what we call the peso
ballistic collapse and it lifts two
empirical models are given a measurement
scenario and a semi ring we have the
notion of a compatible family of
distributions so we've been saying that
the marginals on the overlaps on the
intersections of the of the contexts
coincide makes perfectly good sense so
we have the notion of empirical model
and we write the set of empirical models
over a scenario and a semi ring in this
fashion
so the case we've basically been
studying till now the probabilistic
empirical models are just the case where
we take semi ring to be the non-negative
reals and the possible istic models
where we take it to be the boolean and
everything works all notions relating to
context your allottee global sections
and so on work across this broader
variety of situations and well there's
so in particular so I mean just being
slightly I mean okay so now I've
mentioned the natural transformation if
you have a homomorphism of semi rings it
actually Tran well it translates into a
natural transformation of the
appropriate kind firstly on these
functors D sub R to D sub s and then it
lifts to basically this is the formal
content of what we were saying about it
translating an empirical model with our
value distributions to an empirical
model with s value distributions if you
think in terms of the table
we're just translating the probabilities
or the the entry the R entries in the in
the table from the empirical model over
R into S entries along this homomorphism
and if we apply this in in the case of
this canonical
a morphism here then it's exactly the
possibility collapse and here's a very
simple general fact
but if we have a global section for an
empirical model over the semi-ring are
and we have this homomorphism then we
can translate it in this way into a
global section for the corresponding
model over the semi-ring s so you have
the following result so if you think
about the PI contra position to say with
non contextual is that we have a global
section so what this is saying is that
the is that the property of being a
contextual of not so we the property of
Hamlet's are property of having a global
section is transferred along the
homomorphism so the property of not
having a global section will be
reflected in other words if the if the
image empirical model is contextual if
it has no global section then the
original empirical model must have been
contextual that's just by contra
position if there have been a global
section over e it would have been
translated to a global section over HIV
showing that HIV is non contextual so
non contextual T is preserved contextual
T is reflected in particular if the
possible istic so another another way of
saying that is I mean let's just think
of it with probabilities and
possibilities it's easier to have a
global section possible listicle e than
it is probabilistically it's easier to
have a witness for non contextuality if
you like a hidden variable model
possible listicle e than it is
probabilistically so if we don't have
one possible italy we certainly don't
have one probabilistically the converse
however is not true and this was already
the first part of our hierarchy of
notions probabilistic contextuality a
labelled but bell is not possible istic
li contextual and then probabilistic
contextual attea lahardee
which implies probabilistic contextual
Hamilton so it possible istic and X out
there which implies probabilistic
integer
this is a general fact about these
things okay so and one can develop more
about the hierarchy and that we've
discussed and other unrelated
hierarchies in this in this context but
instead what I want to do is to pick up
on another point that arises from this
which is that given that we now see that
familiar things like boolean and finite
sets just appear naturally in this
language once we take the case with the
boolean with an appropriate semi ring
what happens to our discussion of
contextual 'ti does it have some more
familiar manifestations and one and
indeed it does and here's one that's
particularly close to home here since it
picks up on one of the themes of the
program and a central topic in computer
science namely relational databases the
remarkable thing is that there's an
isomorphism among code I think it's fair
to say between the basic situation we've
been describing or issac from analyzing
contextual 'ti in quantum mechanics and
the basic notions and definitions in
relational database theory and nice
discussions with folks on a few years
ago led to the clarification of this and
so here is a table of the kind that
we've of the way that the database
tables are usually written where we have
these attribute names and then a set of
tuples with a value for each of the
attributes so this we recognize
something about European cooperation
comes to mind here but I'll I'll pass on
that what I want to say is at the tables
we've been writing in the possible
estate case and we're gonna relate this
to the set semantics of databases the
usual set semantics of databases but
indeed by what we've been saying by
taking other kinds of distributions
valued in other semi rings we could also
relate it to different semantics of
databases bag semantics or some version
of probabilistic databases but let's
just take possible istic case and the
hardy model again this can be thought of
as a little relational database the
change of perspective is we now think of
these variables or measurement settings
as the attributes we think of the
outcomes as the data values and we think
of a joint outcome of measuring all the
variables in a context as tuples and
then the rows of the database each turn
into a table in exactly the usual sense
so each row here turns into a little
table with the respective attributes and
you can see in fact that that's
specifying what the contexts are is like
giving the schema of the database it's
saying what are the the set of tables
with their respective attributes so it's
actually a perfect correspondence with
these notions
so given this it's irresistible to ask
the question what is the database
property corresponding to the presence
of nonlocality or contextual 'ti in the
hardy table and the answer is actually a
very classic answer which has already
been described by folk on in his
lectures in fact there was even the the
sort of subject of the universal
relation Wars or right so so the
question is is there a universal
relation is there a big table at least
up in the sky as it were over all the
attributes mentioned anywhere in the
database from which we can recover all
the tables in the database by projection
that is exactly what whether the
question of the existence of a global
section turns into and this was of
course well studied in the ANA deed
debated fiercely debated in the database
community as opposed circa late
seventies early eighties so we can
actually make quite a comprehensive
dictionary as we've just said between
these these notions let me mention this
final entry here which is which is a
beautiful story of its own there's a
beautiful paper by Avila from around
nineteen sixty one of the I guess maybe
the the the main founder of the in that
II area this the era of the Soviet
School of game theory and motivated by
game theory nineteen sixty which notice
is not only before the database notions
but also before Bell's paper he wrote a
paper containing the following result
but if I put it in our terms if you have
an empirical model over a simplicial
complex or a hyper graph scenario as
we've described it exactly satisfying
the compatibility conditions under what
combinatorial conditions on the
structure of the hypergraph can we
guarantee that any such empirical model
will have a global section and he
actually gave combinatorial conditions
on the hypergraph or if you prefer the
abstract simplicial complex necessary
and sufficient conditions to guarantee
this and the conditions are actually
equivalent to the condition we know as
data as a solicitor of data based
schemes it's exactly those conditions so
it's a beautiful paper and ruin his
thesis has looked at a generalization of
this way where you take this over in the
in the setting we've been discussing
over a general
semi-ring okay and yeah because as we've
said because of the this kind of
generalization with different semi rings
we can look at various variants okay so
i'll leave it at that i mean it would be
nice to think that one could build on
this these connections and have some
fruitful results that would come out of
this I mean one direction where where
some progress has already been made is
the work with focus on and Georg which I
which I mentioned briefly in a previous
lecture going into the this direction of
robust constraint satisfaction but I'm
sure there should be things in relation
to databases so now I want to talk about
a topic which brings out this idea that
we can gain information about
probabilistic structure by looking at
possible istic structure and in
particular we can come tantalizingly
close to a full combinatorial
characterization of the no signaling
polytope which as we've seen as a
fundamental object in of study in
contemporary quantum information and
foundations this broader class of
theories which includes the quantum case
but but includes things that go beyond
as well and and trying to understand the
structure of that has been a an
important theme in the current work in
the quantum information area we can come
rather close to a combinatorial
understanding of these polytopes which
are quite complicated high dimensional
objects in possible istic terms but
there remains they remain some questions
which which might well be the kind of
things that progress could be made on
here in this range environment with so
much expertise in any of the relevant
areas so as we've said we can fix a
measurement scenario and this will all
be generic for any
measurement scenario the we get a set of
probabilistic empirical models it's
always convex closed under convex
combinations we can represent the
marbles as points in this high
dimensional space and since it's defined
by a finite number of linear constraints
for each fixed measurement scenario it's
going to be a polytope so remember the
nose think we actually wrote down
examples of the no signaling equations
which these things that expressed that
the marginals appropriate marginals
coincide and together with a non
negativity of course okay so what is the
structure the question is what is the
structure of this poly tope and the when
particular we're focusing here on the
combinatorial structure of poly tope and
one of us says at the core I mean so the
object that's often used to give the
combinatorial structure is the face
lattice so the the the set of faces of
the poly tope ordered by inclusion in
fact the combinatorial type of a
polytope is is defined to be given by
it's the isomorphism type of its face
lattice on the other hand so this is
this is directly the thing obtained from
this poly tope of probabilistic models
on the other hand we have something
that's defined apparently quite
differently namely we have this
possibility collapse which for each
probabilistic model takes us to a
possible istic model so in really which
is which is just a set of boolean
vectors in an obvious way they can be
ordered component wise so we just in
less than month so we just ordered
tables component wise and then the
result is that actually this face
lattice is is isomorphic to this lattice
of possiblest ik models there's just
this slight adjustment in that the face
lattice is taken to include the empty
face and so we need to add a bottom
point to the because obviously we have
the normalization so we don't have the
empty model so if we add that one point
of
bottom we get an isomorphism of these
lattices so that's the result with which
is in joint work with Ruiz Shane
Mansfield rail island Co hakushi de
which I'll describe now in fact the
result applies to a wider class of
polytopes if you think about the way
that the no signalling polytope is
defined the constraints of the linear
equations giving no signaling this this
sort of the fact that marginals coincide
and non negativity so in geometric terms
it's a polytope that's defined by it's a
fine closure
intersected with the with the non
negative authenticity called a non
negative half space intersection of half
spaces I forget the terminology they're
just the set of non negative vectors now
we can say that a polytope is in
standard form if it if it is defined in
this way in other words it's defined by
a set of linear a set of not necessarily
homogeneous linear equations together
with a non negativity constraint it's a
standard result in linear programming
that every linear program can be put in
a standard form where it's given by
equations together with non negativity
so the result is for any poly tope in
standard form there's an isomorphism
between the face lattice and the set of
supports of the points ordered by
inclusions there's a meaningful general
notion of support which generalizes this
idea of possibly lista collapse although
it doesn't really have the
interpretation of the support of a
probability distribution unless we do
actually have the case of a polytope
like them no signalling Politan okay so
just to briefly review usual notions we
have the an idea of polytopes we have
the idea of a face which is given by
specified by an inequality like this and
then the face is that so that if if we
have an inequality valid for the
polytope then the face will be the set
of things which actually satisfy the
equation so it sort of cuts the polytope
at that point and that lower diagonal
point and then the set of faces is
naturally ordered by inclusion and this
is what's called the face lattice and in
fact these are well studied things they
have a lot of structure they're finite
lattice is obviously for a for a
polytope and they're atomistic and
charata mystic and graded so they're
very sort of regular and nice lattices
i'm should note that meats are given
directly by intersection of faces
whereas joins have to be defined
indirectly of course because it's a
finite poset as soon as you have meats
then you also have all joins which are
defined indirectly as the meat of all
the upper bounds but the the definition
sort of works in well you can not so
difficult to define but it's not the one
that's given immediately this is
interesting because of something will
come up later when we look at them I so
more for this lattice right so as we say
this is the face lat is often called the
combinatorial type of the polytope
so it's disregarding metric information
but giving all the information about how
the combinatorial object is built up
from its lower dimensional components
the important notion of interior for a
polytope is the relative interior which
is defined in this in in this fashion
because of dimensionality issues so we
have to take here the the affine closure
of a set in order to get the useful
notion of an interior so point is and
there's a a a nice way of characterizing
this relative interior which has a nice
intuition behind it a point is in the
relative interior of a polytope if the
line segment from any any other point
- it can be extended beyond it while
remaining in this actually this works
for more general more general convex
figures than the polytopes but we only
need it for poly tope so if so a point
is in the relative interior if any other
point to it to this given point can be
extended beyond this point while still
remaining in the in the set and there's
the notion of a carrier face of a poly
tope every poly so as a standard way of
decomposing a poly tope as the disjoint
union of the relative interiors of its
non-empty faces and that means then that
we can define always a map which sends
each point of the poly tope to its
carrier face the unique face in whose
relative interior it lies this is all
as we said a polytope in standard form
we call something like this which more
concretely means it's defined by
equations together with non-negativity
and we can define a support map so this
is the generalization of the possibility
collapse which sends a vector in the non
negative space non-negative orphaned
into just a vector a zero one vector and
it does the same thing we were doing
with the possibility collapse it keeps
zero fix and send anything positive to
one and this naturally has a component
wise ordering and you can see that
there's a natural way of defining the
join as component wise boolean
disjunction and we can see that if we
take the support of a convex combination
of points then they will just be given I
mean this goes to just this point wise
join so what we see then is that and
since this was a convex set to start off
with this we get this closure under
joins and that tells us that this is a
finite partial order which moreover has
all joins therefore by the same
reasoning as we saw before it's a finite
lattice but in this case it's the joins
which are described directly and it's
the meets which have to be described
indirectly
so a meet will be the join of all the
lower bounds yep so we just need to add
a bottom element here in case the zero
vector wasn't in the polytope we started
off with if the polytope did contain
zero then it would be it would be
trivially okay and then we have a very
simple observation which is that we get
this isomorphism that the because of the
fact well it's rather easy to show that
the I mean this is what we're basically
going to show it's about it's a very
simple observation but then this will
tell us automatically that we have so
we're going to have surjective maps from
starting from the polytope either for a
vector to its carrier face or for a
vector to its support and once we show
that inclusion of carriers is equivalent
to this component wise ordering of the
supports will immediately know from this
that there's an isomorphism between
these two partial orders between these
two lattices so that's what we do here
and it's actually a simple argument just
using this characterization of the
relative interior what we basically do
is we show that in fact the cap for a
stat any standard poly tope the carrier
face is just this face given in this
concrete fashion so what we do here is
we we sort of have the complementary
vector which has zeros wherever the
vector we start off with is positive and
ones wherever the vector we start off
with is negative and this then defines a
face which is which is going to be 0
exactly on those vectors whose support
is included in the support of the vector
that we started off with and the main
thing is to show that this this is
indeed in the relative interior of this
of this face and there's
to do that so once we know that then
it's very easy once we've described the
carrier face in these terms to verify
this condition we pretty much directly
buy construction we see that the
ordering on carriers just from this the
way that the carries is defined by these
complex of things generated by these
complimentary vectors correspond
directly to inclusion of supports and
then we get this isomorphism which was
our result and I mean so it's a simple
result but it has some nice consequence
these models are in the relative
interior of the same face if and only if
they have the same support and the
empirical model has full support even if
it only if it's in the relative interior
of the no signaling poly tube so any
logically contextual model must lie in a
proper face the vertices of the no
signaling poly tope are exactly the
probability models with minimal support
moreover there is only one probability
model for each such minimal support so
this is why we said that for example we
said that the PR box was uniquely
determined the probabilities were
uniquely determined from the support by
the no signaling conditions and that is
a very special instance of this general
fact so the equations forced in fact in
that case all the probabilities to be
the same which meant that we had to have
the uniform distribution on each row but
that's actually a completely general
fact so the extremal empirical models we
could say are exactly those models which
are completely and uniquely determined
by their supports and actually what
they're going to be are on the one hand
the deterministic models which certainly
have minimal supports they're going to
have one one one on each row and those
are the those are the vertices of the
non contextual polytope and then they're
going to be the strongly contextual
models with minimal support and those
will generate the rest of the mo
signalling positive so yeah as actually
what I'm saying here so we get in
principle what looks like a very nice
combinatorial description of the no
signaling polytope
there is one snag though which is what's
going to lead to this open question when
I was mentioning by the way I mean I've
only been going a bit far so there was
there any questions about any of this
but these are um
let's transition you're handsome so this
almost looks like a nice combinatorial
description of the no signaling people
it is a nice comment or of description
but lots of nice consequences but there
is one snag and the snag is that we
talked about supports of probabilistic
models so it's not a fully
self-contained combinatorial description
in terms of the possible estate models
what we would like is something that
only talks about the possible estate
models and which picks out the correct
ones to be the vertices of the no
signaling polytope and so the question
broadly is can we characterize the
combinatorial type of the no signaling
polytope using only possible istic
notions so yeah so this is what we've
been saying we get this map that takes
us from probabilistic thing things over
the semi ring of non-negative reals into
the possibility case and we want to give
an intrinsic characterization of the
image of the possible estate collapse
map using only possible istic notions so
there are in fact I should so you know
we sort of already said that there are
examples so I mean one thing we could
ask given a possible istic model is does
it come from a probabilistic a possible
istic no signaling model does it come
from a probabilistic no signaling model
by all the things we're saying about
this translation by homomorphism if you
start with a probabilistic no signaling
model and map it down to it's possible
istic collapse that will certainly be no
signaling it's just a preservation of
equations the question is what about the
converse and the answer is that that as
we might expect since being no signaling
possible istic lee over the boolean
semi-ring is a weaker condition than
being no signalling over the reals over
the non-negative reals there are in fact
quite simple examples of possible istic
empirical models that satisfy no
signaling in the possible it accent's
but are not the support of any
probabilistic empirical model and here's
a fairly simple example of such a thing
if you think about how one would
prove this one will take the no
signaling conditions which and here
we're picking out the the positive
elements with these ones remember so
we're going to get certain equations
that say for example that say this this
is alpha and this is beta sorry this is
probably these comparing this row and
this row we're going to get a no
signaling equation so here is alpha
positive beta positive gamma positive if
the sum of alpha plus beta equals gamma
then we know that for example gamma must
be strictly larger than alpha and beta
so we're going to pick up constraints of
the form of strict orderings between
different elements and the point is in
this example if we look carefully and we
write down all the constraints of that
kind we get we end up with a cycle of
such strict ordering constraint so we
end up with a conclusion that alpha must
be less than alpha which refutes the
possibility that this could have come
from any probabilistic model so we're so
the image is is not it's not a
subjective map
so and all the arguments that we know of
are of that form and it would be nice if
there was a sort of logical theory just
focusing on this issue of the orderings
that can be inferred which would such
that one could prove that a possible
istic model given in these terms came
from a probabilistic one exactly when
this when this theory told you that it
did where the theory didn't refer at all
to the reals or anything outside the
possiblest ik realm okay so we know that
the map is not surjective but we could
ask in the in the case of the minimal
ones maybe very where they have a sort
of fewest number of elements in their
support so they're intuitively perhaps
they won't generate many of these nasty
strict inequality constraints that maybe
they're always realizable as supports so
this seemed promising but it turned out
not to be the case the moderately
complicated counter example so here's a
concrete scenario it looks like this and
could be drawn as a bundle diagram of
the same kind we were looking at earlier
and we'd with three values in general in
each fiber and what we get from the
constraints we there's no signaling
conditions give us a lot of equations
and in the end it tells us that all
variables must be equated because it's
minimal if we say well it is minimal
because if we said any variable to zero
all must be zero so there can't be any
normalized model sitting below it so the
amp but there is a remaining non-trivial
equation which is exactly the one we
don't want a equals a plus a works fine
in boolean algebra but not with positive
reals so therefore there's no real
solution and this can't come from a
probabilistic model and we can actually
convert this into a bail scenario type
example as well with fancy error pick
so it's still an open question to give
an intrinsic characterization of the
image of the possible istic collapse map
using only possible istic notions I mean
that's not a terribly precise
formulation but but I think you know as
I say would be nice to have a logical
theory which directly answer that
question without bringing in the whole
theory of the reals okay so I have a
thought I would say a bit about the
coach inspector theorem which is a
famous result in me in the area Sam you
were a student of coaching is that so
did you ever discuss the theorem with
him well there we are so it's fully
fully referent well I better be careful
if I say oh right right yes of course
yes Allison irrespective very well yes
so right so it's a classic result of the
field and I just want to show how it is
can be seen and fitted into the general
perspective we've been we've been
discussing in these lectures and again
there's a intriguing open problem and
there are some beautiful combinatorial
geometry has been used in the creation
of particular cogent speaker arguments
so what does the coach inspector theorem
do we've rarely discussed Bell's Theorem
and a broad notion of contextual teeth a
particular point which we get from coach
and speaker proofs is that they offer
state independent proofs of strong
content in our language of strong
contextual 'ti in quantum mechanics
remember strong contextuality is the
strongest form and it put it already it
makes it can be expressed purely at the
possibility clever and the extra thing
we get from the coach inspector type
results
is that whereas we would we've been
looking at empirical models which are
generated in the quantum realm by a
state with measurements in in for Coach
inspector type proofs you only need to
see the combinatorial structure of the
measurements and that already tells you
for any possible state that strongly
contextual model will arise so it has an
extra strength in that sense
but there is a sort of trade-off
actually bail some some people refer to
the bail coach inspector theorem because
bill had another paper which was
published I think in 1966 although he
actually wrote it before his 1963 1964
paper I think in 1963 and it spent some
time on a on an editor's desk but it had
a version of and with a different proof
of a coach inspector but Bell was
actually wanted to prove the theorem in
there for his 1964 paper because
although in the sense it has weaker
conclusions
it isn't state independent as we've seen
you need to have specific states to
generate those probabilities but it also
has weaker assumptions the fact that you
have Alice and Bob who are separated
whereas that no such separation is
generally possible with a coach and
speck of proof and indeed Belle type
scenarios in general do not lead to
coach and Specter arguments so you can
have one or the other but people have
been making I mean the other thing about
the Bell argument is that it led Dyer
and led directly to experimental tests
starting with a Spurs work in the 1980s
as we mentioned and culminating recently
in the these recent celebrated
experiments from the end of last year
but people have also been testing an
increasing number of experimental tests
of of contextual 'ti over the last few
years okay so what what is the how can
we how can we give a general formulation
of coach and specular arguments is about
so the the shape of the sort of game
we're going to of the set up we're going
to describe we can that we're going to
have two valued outcomes that will be
quite sufficient and we're going to talk
about possible istic models again
because after all we want to prove
strong contextual T so it is really a
notion that lives that
the possible istic level so so we're so
we just have to give a set of vertices
and this this hyper graph this family of
sets of compatible variables and the the
particular form again can be expressed
completely independently of the issue of
Quantum realization the the model where
we can say that a joint outcome over a
context satisfies the Cochin spec a
property if if exactly one of the
variables in the context takes the value
one so it's a sort of coloring
constraint exactly one of the variables
in each maximal context takes the value
one and we can then define an
appropriate possible istic maximal coach
inspector model by setting the well so
this is going to be a possible a stick
model so it's a boolean can distribution
but we can just think of it as a set so
it's just the set of all those
assignments satisfying the coach
inspector property so really therefore
the model this model is uniquely
determined once we've given the
hypergraph all the information is there
and if we regard the elements of X as
propositional variables we can think of
this as a truth value assignment and in
fact the coach inspector property for an
assignment is equivalent to this formula
being satisfied which is just another
way of saying good exactly one variable
is true but it could be any one okay so
a coach inspector construction in these
terms simply then is a coach inspector
model which is strongly which is
strongly contextual and explicitly in
logical terms that's equivalent to
saying that this formula is
unsatisfiable
yeah and we can generalize it in various
ways we don't have to consider the
two-valued case and then that's kind of
like moving from a satisfiability
problem to a que valued constraint
satisfaction problem so here is
something we saw earlier it's a
particular and well well-known
construction it's one of the simplest
that's available it works in our for
well I mean what that means we'll say in
a moment but it works in our for not in
our three where the the real game is as
it were that will describe shortly so
it's got eighteen variables there's a
measurement cover of nine sets and you
see each each of these sets consists of
four of the variables and we can ask the
question is this a coach inspector
construction so this has a well-defined
meaning for quite generally now it's
about whether this formula is
satisfiable
so can we derive information from the
combinatorial structure of this
configuration that gives us a quick
answer obviously we could enumerate all
the so there is a nice combinatorial
condition and this is a generalization
of once known as the parity condition
that's been widely used in for Coach
inspector so for each set the fridge of
age variable rubber we can define U of x
to be all the contexts that X appears in
and what we can say is that so what
we're asking is just to be I mean just
to sort of get behind this formula is
we're asking for an assignment to all
the variables which then satisfies the
property that exactly one of the
variables is true in each context
and what you can see the sort of salient
thing one can see here is that each
there are nine contexts and each
variable appears in exactly two contexts
and that's going to tell us that there
can be no such assignment and here is
the more general a more general form of
that combinatorial condition if there is
such an assignment then every common
divisor of the set of all these sort of
appearance numbers incidence numbers of
all the variables must divide the
cardinality of the hypergraph the number
of contexts that we have it's a nice
thing to think about it's not
particularly hard to prove and applying
this to the above example we noticed
that the cover has nine elements each
element of X appears in two members so
greatest common divisor is two and it
doesn't divide nine so we conclude that
this is contextual there's a nice take
on this with Co homology which I haven't
talked about in these lectures so it
fits in nicely with that picture as well
so homology detects all of these all of
these cases of contextual tea okay so
this is all purely combinatorial and
doesn't and as yet we haven't indicated
any connection with quantum mechanics so
the other side of the picture is to say
when does one of these contextual coach
and spec of models give rise to a
quantum mechanics witness of contextual
'ti and the idea is this and this is
well it's quite of course quite related
to the things that Simona was talking
about and also goes back to the well I
mean some of the the main general facts
about this kind of thing go back to this
work of a lavash so we so what we get is
a witness when we can label X
with unit vectors in RN for some fixed n
such that the families of sets that
we're considering in our cover in our in
our set of context consists of those
subsets which form author normal basis
what we specifically have to say that
those things which are subsets form
orthonormal basis so therefore they're
all going to be the same size and the
point of our previous example with the
18 vectors in the nine contexts each
with four elements is that we can label
those 18 elements with vectors in our
four such that the four element subsets
are indeed orthogonal so this is one of
the most economical known examples of a
coach inspector construction an
interesting point is at the triangle
that we've we've discussed a couple of
occasions this very simple configuration
which would be a perfect example of a
coach inspector model I mean this is so
if we want only one of the vertices in
each for each edge to have the value one
and we get to clearly get an argument
for strong contexture ality the problem
with realizing this in this way is that
is that the notion of orthogonality
we're using is a pairwise notion so if
all the pairs are orthogonal then the
whole set will be compatible so we don't
get we don't get a witness from the
speaker triangle which is why Cochin and
speaker had to come up with a much more
elaborate example but we'll come back to
that in a moment given such a fact so we
still haven't fully made the connection
with observables the kind of
measurements as we've been talking about
throughout the week so how do we do that
this part is often skipped in
presentations so I think it's useful
just to mention this so given such a
family of vectors we can construct
observables corresponding to each
compatib
family where the outcomes if you like
encode the eigenvectors eigenvalues i
should be saying this means that for any
state the result of measuring actually I
do mean that so so therefore the point
is that that encoding will guarantee
this coach and spec a property that we
were mentioning that whatever out that
each outcome that we can get will
correspond to coloring exactly one of
the vectors in that in that context
therefore in the orthonormal basis
associated with the that observable
exactly one of them will be picked out
get that get be colored one all the
others will be colored 0 so the Cochin
spec a property is built in and that's
independent of which state we use it's
just a feature of the structure of the
measurement itself and that's why this
is going to yield a state independent
argument so hence we get a state
independent proof of strong contextual T
in quantum mechanics wherever we have
such a labeling and there are some
conditions given the in the case of
graphs there are there are conditions
given by lavash and co-authors about
when when such when suitable colorings
would be possible but it's not a
complete characterization okay so now we
come to the the sort of a challenge
problem that's been ok as around quite a
lot of interest which is of obtaining
coach and spec of constructions we saw
an eighteen vector construction in four
dimensions of course the more dimensions
you have the easier it gets to construct
such examples but the the minimum
dimension in which such examples can be
constructed is three and that's where
Cochin inspector gave their original
proof so there's particular interest in
obtaining coach inspector constructions
in our three one connected so one can
prove that you just can't get such a
thing in
in our to it's an interesting point that
that specular actually had a paper in
1960 which really can as a beautiful
paper which has been sort of re
revisited and discussed a lot last few
years as a beautiful parable of the seer
for example which is very nice to read
and this triangle incidentally and but
and he sort of as a throwaway remark he
sort of says and obviously this sort of
situation can be realized in in quantum
mechanics but it seems this didn't have
too much of an effect so several years
later coaching the speaker came back
with their paper and they really
constructed an example with 117 vectors
39
39 bases in r3 there's a there's a
famous picture of sort of a now these
things are inscribed on the sphere the
current record is 31 obtained from the
construction by Paris and there are some
there's also ideas by Penrose and the
Penrose dodecahedron I think it is and
some some very nice to use has been made
of combinatorial geometric
configurations in order to generate
small smaller into degenerate families
of rays which will give rise to coach
and speaker arguments so the smallest
known number is 31 they were spin there
was some work a few years ago by Jill
Joaquin and one of his students which
established a lower bound of 18 with a
lot of computation as well as a lot of
clever analysis and that was recently
improved to 22 by two students at
Nijmegen in the party AQAP's group so
the current lower bound is 22 and upper
bound is 31 okay so yes I think that has
been used to some extent but I think you
know often you can by finding a suitable
combinatorial argument you could kind of
shortcut but but there has been a lot of
computational exploration
they've been particularly a couple of
authors have a church and colleagues who
have who've done quite a lot of
computational exploration I think the
work by Joel was more using
computational and geometry tools I think
yes in principle one one could but of
course one's exploring you know a big
space of possible
so coming back from that particular
topic just to just to wrap up this this
series of lectures briefly so I just
want to come back I mean if our sort of
message particularly in this lecture has
been that we can find similar structures
further afield for example this
connection with databases or constraints
so it's natural to ask the question why
do such similar structures arise in
apparently different settings and I
think I'd be prepared to argue I mean I
think it's not too outlandish to argue
that the phenomenon of contextual tea is
pervasive and this idea of local
consistency global inconsistency even a
familiar enough phrase I mean certainly
well-known and constraints and once we
start looking for it we can find it in
many places of course what would be good
is to have a common mathematical
structure and have a sort of a theory
with some breadth of applications so
we've discussed a lot connections with
quantum information foundations which is
the main motivation as far as I'm
concerned but there certainly are these
wider and wider things as well and I'll
mention a couple of papers just when I
finish up I mean there's papers are
available on the archive as an overview
there was a recent paper in The Bulletin
of EA TCS also available on the archive
which which might be a sort of good
thing to look at and I just thought I'd
show and mention some of the people I've
had the pleasure of working with on
these things and Brandenburger of him I
sort of introduced the general setting
I've mainly been
using as a framework for discussing
things in these lectures Lucy and Hardy
we've heard of the Hardy paradox and he
worked with him on logical Bell
inequality is really who's here Shane
will be visiting later I mentioned the
work on robust constraint satisfaction
with folk Ian and Georg and Linda's here
Giovanni will be visiting later both
doing their PhDs in related topics
Carmen constant in Carey Kishida and
Manish Sandra's are there so actually
I've be delighted if I can add to this
list over the course of this of this
program see here's a few references if I
was very much for staying with me during
the week and that's the amount it thanks
the 90th birthday for Schmidt can I
check the citation it was around three
four hundreds and I chickened out for
the caution it's over 2,000 yes yes and
and the interest is I mean as I say
people are now doing experiments for
testing contextual tea and and the one
of the remarkable things about quantum
information is that things that were
seen as very foundational have become
much closer to things at the scene as
you know really connected with with
applications in the field so absolutely
incidentally Anton Zeilinger likes to
show a graph of the EPR paper from the
mid 1930s which shows this remarkable
exponential growth as well
and you say if there is anything related
between contact your arty and
conventional notion of conserved
quantities quantities Massey could help
me I'm not sure the it seems to sit in
there different I mean obviously there
are things like energy and so on I mean
I I don't quite see the connection what
does seem to I mean so I think you know
we discussing yesterday the issue of
quantifying contextual tea and I think
there are clearly robust measures and
but this is all that somehow at the
level of information and the quantum
information the sort of information
revolution in physics is bringing it
much closer to maps the way of thinking
about things that we where we are
familiar with sort of logic in computer
science community a lot of physicists
are still resistant to that trend that
they think of information there's
something as it were you know sort of
that we project onto the world rather
than something fundamentally physical
but I think the ideas may have to change
as as you know these developments
quantum technologies and so on continue
but I don't know of any anything precise
to say
have to wait for the workshop on
symmetry yes
by then the aim is that they shall we
break for lunch okay right